the permanence of the random matrix with
vanishing me
maybe should throw yeah
right thanks for coming to this talk so
I'm going to talk about my recent work
with Lee or el dólar here's the archive
number and so the title is approximating
the permanence of a random matrix with
vanishing mean before starting I'll give
you a very quick overview of the outline
of the talk so at the beginning I'm
going to express the main question which
is related to the complexity of the
permanence in a particular setting and
I'm going to tell you why we should care
about this particular setting and the
main motivation comes from quantum
supremacy experiments and understanding
the advantage of quantum computers over
classical ones after that I'm going to
tell you what previous spells we know
about the complexity of the permanence
related to the computer the particular
setting that we consider and then I'm
going to explain our results at the end
I'm going to go over the proof
techniques which is based on zeroes of
random polynomials and the interpolation
method that they have been talking about
throughout this workshop ok so what is
the parallel polynomial if we know the
determinant it is easy to understand it
if you have a complex matrix of size n
times n then permanent is like the
determine except that we don't have this
sign factor here so it's sum over all
permutations of an N element set and
multiplies so and multiplies the element
in each entry selected according to that
permutation for example for a 2 by 2
matrix
the permanent is multiplicative
multiplication of these two elements a11
a.22 plus a12 a21 and the difference
between the determinant is this negative
sign so even though the they are so
similar we know that's like determinant
is computable in polynomial time
but parent has very interesting
complexity behavior so it's hard to
compute from most cases that we know the
main question that this talk focuses on
is to understand the complexity of the
permanent and a setting where we
consider approximation and average case
so we can think of computing a function
exactly or approximately or we can think
of computing a function for all
instances or like for most instances
where each return as average case so
this talk is about the particular case
when we combine approximation and
randomness approximation and average
case so why should we care about this
setting well it's an interesting
question
and it is related to well-known
properties of the permanent for example
random self reducibility and so on which
I'm going to talk in more detail in a
bit but the main motivation that I'm
going to attract their attention is the
quantum advantage that I'm going to
explain what is the main open question
that you're trying to understand and
resolve and how does this question
relate to this like the interpolation
technique and roots of polynomials and
so on so in recent years in an ongoing
of an ongoing research we are trying to
show that even though the full function
and quantum computer is out of reach if
we can prove we want to show that like
even weak computers quantum computers
that are too small and like very weak in
their functionality or they can still do
do computations that classical computers
cannot do so one particular example of
such a model is known as boson sampling
which I'm going to explain to you using
a very simple classical setup so
consider the setting that like you have
balls and bins so
have been number one here been number
number two here and I consider that like
you have one ball per each of those
beans and the balls are
indistinguishable and I want to look at
the and at each spin I have the I
consider the probabilistic process that
I move the ball let's say at at the
first day and I move it to the second
min I do it with poverty p12 or keep it
in the same manner for me TP one one and
the same for the second min and I'm
interested in the in the events that
like I start with one ball in each pin
and I end up with one ball in each pin
so it turns out that well there are four
possibilities at the end of this process
so I can have two balls and the first
thing or two balls in the second mirror
above all in in each of those but
they're setting that that is deflected
in this picture the probability is going
to be the permanence of this matrix P
which basically encodes the privacy of
transitions between bins so that is
basically how the permanent gets encoded
into a very simple model that like you
can think of it as a model of
computation and I can generalize this
model to more balls and bins and let's
say I have more bins and balls and I
have ambos the located in the first M
bins and I'm again interested in the
events that I end up with M balls and
the first ambience and I'm again
interested in the probability of this
event I show the denoted P to be the
probability matrix whose entry I J is
the policy of moving a ball at being I
to the to the bin J so turns out that
the probability of these events now is
going to be the permanence of the top M
by M sub matrix of P so I have a
classical model that encodes in its
probabilities the interesting
computational problem even though this
doesn't mean that the model can compute
the permanent but let's for now ask that
how hard is it to approximate the
probabilities of the events coming out
of this model of computation so based on
a very non
results of Jim Sinclair and Vigoda we
know that's if you have a matrix that
doesn't have negative numbers in it then
we can compute the approximate the value
of the permanence of such matrix in
randomized polynomial time so mainly we
have an FP RS and in this case since
this matrix P is a stochastic one and
doesn't have negative numbers it turns
out that actually the permanence and the
probability of transitions for this
model is feasible is tractable okay so
now I want to add some quantumness to it
I'm not going through the physics but
the quantum model the boson sampling
model which was introduced by arason on
arkhipov in this line of quantum
supremacy experiment and they were
trying to argue that like this model
even though it doesn't capture a
universal and full functioning quantum
computer cannot be sampled using a
classical computer computers all this
surprising statements hold in complexity
theory
so the bosons something is like again
the balls and bins model instead of
balls now have identical photons and
instead of bins of optical modes there
are the same things and instead of the
probabilistic transition of these balls
between modes I have a linear optical
network whatever that means
that induces some evolution in the model
so the model is that I pass through
photons here and at the end I sample a
certain configuration out of this so I
can think of this again having one
photon in each optical more than ending
up with one photon in optical mode
because we have quantum mechanics
instead of stochastic matrices the
evolution is governed by unitary
matrices which are like complex
generalizations of all orthogonal
matrices it turns out that using simple
and like similar arguments that the
probability of let's say the event that
I start with one photon in each optical
mode and ending up with one photon in
each optical mode the probability is
going to be now the permanence of a
unitary matrix and
related to the parents of you know
metrics and the particulate is absurd
permanence of the mill the unitary
matrix is squared and if I have less
photons than optical modes then I'm
going to get the parent of sub matrices
of a unitary matrix so now what is
relevant about this model to understand
is that I have a model that I can
prepare an arbitrary unitary matrix of
let's say size n times N and I can this
model encodes the in it's probability of
transitions and codes the parent of sub
matrices of this unitary matrix so now I
ask the same question again how hard is
it to come approximate the probability
of the events coming out of this quantum
computer well this using if I understand
the complexity of this exactly exactly
so the understanding this question can
lead to a statements about sampling so
if I know that the approximation of the
probabilities for this model is so sharp
Ehart for example then i can argue that
the existence of a classical computer
can sample from this distribution
implies that the sum the distribution
even though exactly you can feel
probability you shall be hard to
simulate the distributions is yes some
of you the model is just classical
distribution
to compute probability exactly that that
is because the probability of that event
was feasible in randomized polynomial
time but if we show that the probability
is actually not computable not it's not
the cannot be approximated in the
classical polynomial time then that
means a classical computer something
from this distribution implies that
within the so-called polynomial
hierarchy you can approximate these
computational problems which is that
that is basically what they do and are
you that quantum advantage comes from
yeah we can talk offline thank you okay
so again like this is not the
computational model that this small
performs that's the unit set this the
model is basically something one but for
now I'm considering just the complexity
of the the probability that is encoded
in this morning and it turns out that
now like the computer the approximation
of the the permanence is sharpy hard in
the worst case and this was shown by
answering and arkhipov and now what is
different here is that they have
negative numbers in the entries of these
matrices so that is basically a very
slight intuitively if you understand
where quantum advantage is coming to to
the play and is basically having
negative numbers like summing terms that
interfere with each other and cancel out
so I'm going to say just a very few
words will about like how this court of
supremacy setting is again so as we
discussed like the the the goal is to
show that sampling from these balls on
computers are it's hard for a classical
computer
and in their work in Essaouira ocupado
in 2010 showed that if there is a
classical computer that can if there is
a classroom you can sample exactly from
the outputs of these Bolton computers
then we have surprising statements in
complexity theory namely that the
polynomial hierarchy collapses which is
the conjecture to be false like and is a
generalization of P versus NP conjecture
so now we can ask them but have we
established quantum supremacy the answer
is no because even a quantum computer
cannot sample exactly from its outlet
distribution and because we have noise
we have experimental error and so on so
the relevant question is how hard is it
for a classical computer to sample
approximately from the output of such
quantum computer and by the a good toy
model for approximate sampling is total
variation distance in a work is on an
archive of f2 conjectures to the picture
and one of them is about this exactly
the question that I asked at the
beginning of the talk that how hard is
it to approximate the permanence of a
Gaussian matrix with high probability
and the Galaxy matrix has come into the
picture because the salt matrices of the
random informations are close together
so they they come up with a clean
statement of a conjecture and we hope to
find the answer okay so now I'm going to
explain to you the previous bounds that
we know about the hardness of the
prevalent in this particular setting and
tell you what final result what we what
do we add to the picture so first even
though paragraph is solve a factorial
terms by a formula by a ricer we know
how to compute it in exponential time
and we haven't been able to improve on
that's like sort of worst case instances
for exact computation or maybe saving
some
factors it asked the question that how
can we actually do better can I compete
a parent in polynomial time in a seminal
work in 79 volumes showed that probably
the answer is no because then for a zero
one matrix the permanence is sharpy hard
to compute exactly and as I mentioned so
we can ask like have an approximation so
that is the picture for the exact
computation what can we say about
approximation
jerem Sinclair Bogota in 2004 showed
that if you have no negative entries
then you will have FPS fully polynomial
randomized approximation scheme
hopefully I will tie it up with a
randomized approximation so again we ask
the question not what is the complexity
of approximation not having this
constraint like namely that's like you
have can have negative numbers we can
show that that you have even
approximation is high the proof of this
was appeared in the paper by Aaronson an
archival but how it was known before
that and very recently like the topic of
this workshop we have been able like by
the results of our Enoch we have been
able to compute approximate the
permanence for particular instances of
matrices that can have negative or
complex numbers which I just call it
that say mind interference or like which
we have been talking about throughout
this workshop okay so all of these
results were like about the complexity
of the permanence in the worst case now
what can we say about the average-case
complexity of the president so in a
series of work the last of which being
by Kai and others from 99 it was shown
that the permanence is hard to compute
on average so in particular if you
consider a finite field of large enough
prime order then if you have a black box
that can come
the permanence exactly for let's say 1
over infraction of such matrices yes I
should also mention this independence
they also do too yeah so they use the
the use the least decoding my module
soon on that yeah so how you so Matthew
comes before it so there I think there
are four sequence of works that lead to
that okay okay okay yeah thanks for
pointing this I mention okay yeah so
then it's like you're the the permanent
is the heart for event or to come to be
computed for one Rapala fraction of
matrices or a finite field so this
observation was the main reason that
Arizona occup of use this boson model of
quantum computer because they knew that
permanent appears their impairment has
this random self reducibility property
so they were hoping to get some robust
complexity that like when you implement
these in a in an experiment you would
hope that like you would get a
distribution over instances that that is
actually hard to compute so what they
showed was they studied the complexity
of these zero mean Gaussian matrix and
missions and they were able to show that
on average it's hard to compute these
matrices of the permanence exactly but
that didn't solve their problem and as I
said the main open question in the field
is to understand the setting where
average case an approximation are
combined so having these this background
I think I'm ready to explain the main
results initial so we show that if you
have a Gaussian matrix M of Gaussian is
uses the nonzero mean but vanishing us
and the size of the matrix goes to
infinity the mean goes to zero then
still the exact computation is sharp a
hearth well this is this comes from the
proof techniques that existed before but
the main thing is that now when I
combine approximation in
average-case the approximation becomes
feasible when quasi-polynomial time so
we give a natural example of a
computational problem that it is hard to
compute exactly an average but only when
approximation and average case are
combined the problem becomes easy
so that counters the intuition that
having this results will imply that this
box is also sharply hard so what so ok
so let me zoom into the results that we
are dealing with the complexity bounce
that we want to understand so this chart
studies worst case versus average case
exact versus approximation so for a
Gaussian with zero mean and variance one
the worst case exact computation
includes
zero one waitresses a Sharpie heart even
approximation is sharp in high because
it can have negative numbers and the
result of ensign an occupant average
case exact is hard now the last box is
the where we are interested and where we
can have applications where quantum
supremacy is based on and our results in
more detailed is that we fill out this
chart first we show that this chart
still remains this box is the remains
shrubby heart and if you have again a
dancer of Gaussian matrices with mean
whatever poly log log in EE log in the
size of the matrix then you'll get a
quasi polynomial time approximation
algorithm and if you further increase
the mean value to 1 over poly log n then
you you will get some exposure to
another so to recap here is the hardest
landscape for the permanent with respect
to the mean of the thin symbol so if the
mean is zero it's conjectured to be hard
to approximate like if the mean value is
so there should be a threshold for the
mean that like the hardness is the same
as zero mean it turns out that that if
the mean is like 1 over a square root of
n divided by some margin of constant and
the values are within multiplicative
value factors of each other so like here
you will have this conjecture to be hard
if you increase the means for one of our
poly log in you will get some
exponential time algorithm and if you
increase the mean by one of our poly log
low again you will get quasi-polynomial
time algorithm so these were the main
results of this work and if you increase
the mean to MU square root of log in
well I'm not sure how interesting
distance symbol is but but all entries
become positive with all problems with
high probability then using results of
Jim Sinclair and ego that you will get
random West polynomial so as you go from
left to right the problem becomes easier
and easier okay so now I'm going to
sketch the proof and the proof is based
on the interpolation technique that we
have been talking about okay so let me
briefly just go over the the machinery
of the interpolation method which was
introduced by Barbado and so we have
said I want to compute the permanence of
a matrix a I consider a univariate
polynomial G of Z being permanent of 1
minus Z times j j is the all one's
matrix plus z times a is the matrix that
i want to compute the permanence for and
at Z equals 0 I have just the matrix J
the parent of J so the value is just n
factorial and Z equals 1 at the parent
of a and somehow I want to interpolate
from left to right so trouts I'm going
to denote F to be the logarithm of the
polynomial G ok so how do we deal with
this so let's consider this algorithm
that I just Taylor expand
this the log of the parent if I computed
at point 1 then exponentiation gives me
the value of the permanent and so I sum
over let's say M terms and I will obtain
some additive error epsilon and then I
exponentiate so additive error epsilon
becomes multiplicative or absolute no
like any other algorithm we can think
about running time and correctness and
it turns out that if if I need up to M
derivatives here in terms in the Taylor
expansion then the running time is n to
the power order M because the elf
derivative is computable - in time n to
the power L and so for example if I get
M equals logon that I get was if on the
other side for the correctness as we
have been discussing the the if you are
if it turns it's related to the roots of
this univariate polynomial if they are
all outside of the unit circle it's some
significant margin then I would get so
it turns out that like log and many
terms in this Taylor expansion is enough
but if I have only one roots inside this
unit circle then the the the error blows
up very quickly so what I want is to
push all the roots outside
okay so there are two primary challenges
first to understand something about the
location of roots and second like how
knowing something about these roots how
can we do turn around them and compute
approximate the value right so in our
method instead of like considering the
permanence of one minus Z times J plus
za they consider the permanence of J
plus Z times de and the reason that we
do this is just for convenience so if
you consider if you sample a to be an
end times and Gaussian matrix with mean
0 and variance 1 and if I divide this
polynomial X Z to the N then I would get
the determinant of a matrix that the
matrix is such that as if I've sampled
it from a Gaussian distribution with
mean 1 or Z and variance 1 so now I
starts with at point 0 I know how to
compute the permanence and its
derivatives at point 0 now I go as far
as I can so the larger increased Z the
smaller mean that I get here so and I
hope that I go I hope that I can do this
for a large enough Z so that the bound I
obtain would be for a small mean matrix
okay so the main technical contribution
that we make four to four in order to
understand the roots is to find a way to
balance the number of roots of a part a
polynomial on average so basically if we
do an average case very fine an average
case bound for the number of roots of a
polynomial inside a certain disc inside
a second disc in the worst case like
these roots can be anywhere when we show
that if you denote and some are to be
the number of roots of this polynomial
GZ inside a disk of radius R in the
complex plane then in expectation value
S sub R is order R squared okay so the
goal is to do this polynomial
interpolation and go as far as I can and
suppose that I want to compute the
permanent for a matrix that it's a whose
mean value is a very small constant that
says ten ten to the power minus 12 so
that very small constant but this bound
tells me that with high probability then
so I want to choose the R to be 10 to
the power 12 and this bound term tells
me that like with high probability
number fruits inside this disc is going
to be 10 to the power 24 it is large and
not feasible on a classical computer
that we can actually a laptop computer
but it is still a constant in a
synthetic limit the main importance is
that this town doesn't depend on and the
the size of the matrix so so so let me
tell you very quickly about how we show
this so the proof is based on a
well-known formula in complex analysis
known as the Jensens formula if we do a
because we find a bound like you know
an average case we find an average case
version of the Genesis formula so what
is the instance formula consider let's
say you have a polynomial that is not 0
at the origin and I if I integrate the
polynomial did this value log of G of r
e to the power theta so log of G and
absolute G at these the points on this
circle divided by the G at point 0 then
taking this integration is equal to sum
of all the roots inside this this so
that this bound is the depends only on
the roots that are inside this disk of
log of R divided by the modulus of the
root so using a little bit of work and
taking the expectation and so on we can
show that the expectation value of this
this number and R is going to be a
constant times log of the second moment
of this polynomial normalized by the
value at point 0 Jensen's inequality
right yeah this is Jensen's formula and
then Genesis really cool for justice for
me injustice inequality exactly so this
inequality say trust from yeah yeah the
same trips helps us a lot
ok so and we can do this because the at
points is equal 0 the permanent is just
not parent of J and lecture the value is
not 0 so we can use this and since this
is a constant all we need to do is to
compute the second moment of the
permanence of a matrix with nonzero mean
okay so now the second task is to
convert this this take the this
observation into an algorithm so how do
we do this so with high probability we
know that so let's say this is 0 and
this is a large constant and we know
that there are constantly many roots on
the way
we consider a lot of curves that that
attach point zero to point our and we
consider a fattening around each of
these curves so if the number of these
curves are large and the the width of
these tubes around these curves is a
small enough then my simple counting
arguments we can say that most of these
curves should be root 3 so that means
that taking a random curve should be
route free with high probability and
just a technicality is that it's
important that I don't have a roots very
close to the origin or the roots very
close to the final point so along with
showing that the constant bound on the
number of roots we show that there is a
safe disc at all points you want a safe
this ground point or and having that
looked like using this counting argument
we can have faith that taking one of
these terms at random you won't have a
route around it with a significant
margin okay so now let's say this curve
when we have sampled and we have faith
that this is root 3 what can we do well
we can simply just consider a sequence
of curves that the function is analytic
inside and we go from left to right so
this is just for the intuition because
so for example like if I have sequence
of overlapping discs then I compute a
lot of derivatives at point zero and
then use those to compute a lot of their
everything's at the first point of the
the center of the first circle and
continue all the way here and at each
point I discovered a fraction of these
derivatives and do an analysis and or
show that much for the particular regime
of the mean value and so on the arrow
converges so
this is for a Twitter version there is a
maybe a cleaner way to do this that I
just mention it quickly that like if you
have let's say the roots freeze trip
like instead of for this then based on a
result of Marvin oak that's like at the
same time that they introduced the
interpolation technique they don't want
no come on you wasn't my talking that
much at the might see right oh it wasn't
where I explained this may be very close
to each other okay alright so there is a
polynomial of low degree that snaps a
unit disk onto this is trip but we're
incited this is trip and so let's say if
the width of this strip is a constant
and then I would get let's say the
constant parameter beta which like
implies that I need little not many
derivatives and all we add for this is
to compose it further with the analytic
function to go to and to the curve that
we are interesting so that is basically
just the minimal technicality that how
to do this algorithm okay so I want to
point out to to open questions well the
first one is basically the complexity of
the approximate in the permanent with 0
mean and variance 1 well what can we say
about this so let me tell you what what
we believe should be true using some
numerical and Alex we witness that if I
consider this random polynomials like G
of a being parent of Z is 1 minus Z
times J plus C times a so now the same
original
interpolation now the roots of this
polynomial cluster very tightly around a
circle or like something like a circle
around 0 is 1 so in a way Z equals 1 is
protected by armor fruits so that means
like I may not hope to interpret all the
way here and using some heuristics on
conjectured and the concentration
balance on the value of the permanence
or like the bouncer the value of the
parents and expectation and so on we
believe that this the radius of this
circle should be somewhere around one of
our school movement so that means that
if this is true if we can show this
let's say that there are no roots
outside of this circle then that means
the best mean value that we can hope for
is going to be somewhere around whatever
a square root of it like some constant
times 1 over the square root of it and
the bounds would be some explanation
time expert school movement and like as
I said like mean value 1 over square
root of n like divided by some large
enough constant is as hard as than the
the mean value 0 so the other thing that
I want to point out is what can I say
having this problem promised that the
roots are in a unit circle like can we
come up with a clever algorithmically I
think having this promise or two maybe
we are able to disprove the conjecture
and another thing we can ask is that for
example like let's say you if you have
an NP Oracle that can actually tell you
that like these are the location of
roots can you verify this and like for
example having this promise on the
having being roots on the unit circle
and basically interpolates remove these
roots and interpreter
the second open question I want to
mention is them that what can we say
about the statistical properties of
random polynomial using this
interpolation technique so we believe
that like these techniques are
algorithmic but can we use those in
order to say something about random
matrix theory or theory of random
polynomials so and the second conjecture
in the in the bosom sampling paradigm is
known as the anta concentration
conjecture which basically says that the
probability that the absolute value of
the permanent is greater than a square
root of n factorial by some polynomial
in n when a sample from a Gaussian
matrix is high and a square root of n
factorial is the expectation value so
expectation value of the parent squared
is n factorial so we think that
expectation is around the square root of
the factorial for the absolute
determinant so now the question we ask
is can we show this at this for nonzero
mean permanence and so for example
around any point the deviation of the
permanent is at least the square of the
square root standard deviation divided
by some polynomial so I just want to
mention two observations which don't
flee to a proof but can we actually use
this observation to say use it elsewhere
so the first observation is the
machinery of this watch which basically
shows that for mean value 1 over poly
log log n then we can approximate the
log of the parent using a low degree
polynomial in complex Gaussian variables
the second observation is the result of
Kamerion right from 2001 that shows that
actually we know auntie concentration
bounds for low degree polynomial
Gaussian variables so it can be somehow
combine these two to prove some sort of
anti concentration bound for the random
permanence so unfortunately it's OD here
is the the degree of the polynomial and
that the concentration probably that we
get is 1 minus D to the times Epsilon
the deviation here the power of 1 over D
unfortunately this is not sharp enough
to give us any interesting
bounds on the concentration but maybe if
we can sharpen this bound for the
particular case of the permanence that
they have maybe we get some results or
can we use this interpolation so it may
be when we don't know actually how to do
this algorithmically but like knowing
that there is a low degree interpolation
can we say something about its testicle
statistical properties of random
polynomials great references and that's
all I wanted to say thank you questions
you're Mark Spitz
suggestions so but they still don't
understand one thing
so the fact that the German we could
have that result there it's not
absolutely has nothing to do the fact
that you can you can simulate the
distribution it was known for age right
okay so even if I know how to simulate
the distribution it does not mean that
they can do a summation for those
probability so that is true if you have
yeah yeah yeah so if you have approaches
if you have a randomized I went into a
sample but that is a setting your then I
can do the approximation within the
polynomial hierarchy better than the
third level of the polynomial hierarchy
but that is correct that doesn't mean
that I have efficient algorithm but the
the baby reason about it is the other
way that there is actually a much
stronger than level of polynomial
hierarchy algorithm that can approximate
these values for the classical version
of this model but you're right that
doesn't imply it's Gabby's peepers again
there was even like when I included they
did not use that [ __ ] okay so maybe T
1 implies but this would not so they got
that that's just for the intuition they
they used it II did not use the factory
they just wanted to give the intuition
that's like this is these negative
numbers are what any questions that your
cart this results is it oh based on the
fact that this
the chip with the permanent the zero or
not maybe you can do it that way too but
then it is basically there's no hellige
approximation yes if you can do relative
information you at least can distinguish
between zero non zero
yes but they're hard the hardness result
is for exact computation on average yeah
so it's more okay so the non average is
just most cases just if you can it's
known the government to check whether
it's zero notice it's hot right so what
is the idea for the exact no forever
which one this blue for average case
exact computation hardest yeah so it's
basically like assuming that you have an
Oracle that like that tells you the
answer correctly some of the times then
we sample bunch of these like feminists
for that G of Z at four different points
and it's about a lot of those and using
the least decoding and like the these
techniques are we which maybe say that
okay so there there is a way to recover
this polynomial then we interpolate as
equals at the point that I want and then
I do the approximation but it is
basically immediate from the stuff that
was done before
so the similar connectors for these
classical I could be against so we have
natural fall so that hammering hardness
for evaluating easing model with random
complex White's
sure also a message I try to produce the
same result there so there you nothing
you have a partition function you want
to interpolate it all the way to beta
equals one or something like that the
best heuristic found I could find this
like beta equals one over square root of
n which I don't think if it is
interesting I mean if I could show like
one minus one over little or one or
something like that that would be
interesting so I think they are
connector is about you have come taper
off and each edge is a Gaussian break
things you discreet know like power the
branch in case the market has sure
take the other questions or concerns hey
so let us thank the speakers yes